hello everyone welcome to
alexa and friends the special
opportunity we have once in a while
to interview a bunch of people that are
meaningful to the world of alexa
my name is jeff lankenberg uh you
probably know that by now but
uh i am very fortunate to have with me
today
gogunter who is a senior principal
scientist
on the alexa ai team so gogan thank you
for being here
thank you yeah thanks for having me
certainly so
um there's a couple of things that i
like to do at the top of every one of
these interviews which is give a little
give people a little glimpse into kind
of who you are and
i've mentioned to you that i like to ask
these silly questions but i really think
they do a good job of
illustrating for people kind of a little
bit about how you think or
or you know what what your beliefs are
so the first one that i like to ask
is if you could choose any superpower
so imagine all the comic books you may
have read as a child or anything like
that or movies you've seen
you only get to pick one power right so
superman is a combination of a bunch of
powers
um but if you just get to pick one what
superpower would you pick and then of
course why
yeah i have uh i have seen you're asking
this
question to others and i have been uh
thinking
and you know waiting for this question
to come
it's actually a tough question yeah it's
it's a tough question
um and uh at some point i actually you
know
thought of a real good one uh and then i
forgot to write it down and
i cannot still remember that um but uh
one thing you know for sure is that
um i think um i am more on the you know
logical mathematical side sometimes i
just you know
wish to get a number i know that that
number exists
like a stupid example is um like you
know how many uh trees you know
i can see at this moment uh and you know
there's a
you know uh correct answer to that so it
is correct it is
non-arguable it is nothing like i will
do anything with it
but you know sometimes i want to uh know
that number
um and uh i
for some of the things of course you
know you can do a web search you know
try to
get an approximate thing like how many
covet cases but you know there's
actually a number
uh you know number of people in my
country who is actually positive
uh or you know it can be uh anything um
related to history uh like you know who
actually you know killed this guy
uh you know who would trigger some facts
um and i am uh interested in history
um and uh the second interest is uh
space
uh like you know uh what is out there uh
because you know it is a fact you know
when you go beyond
uh the galaxies uh you know how many
galaxies uh
there's an arm and
there's a fact and uh i don't think you
know nobody will ever have that kind of
superpower
but i really wish i had wow that's
really interesting so
uh i don't know how to quantify that
exactly but that's a really interesting
superpower it's basically kind of like
all-knowing but it could also be
somebody that could
travel to any place in time and space
because then you could verify those
things rather than just knowing them
uh yeah yeah yeah so it's just not
subjective you know
there's a fact yeah uh we're gonna call
you fact man i like that this is uh
that's a that's a good superpower i
think that would be incredibly valuable
that's a good i like that a lot
um all right let's let's do
uh let's do two more uh there's one more
that i like to ask i
do you play any kind of music do you
play game instruments
oh no no i am super bad in those things
no that's okay
uh but do you enjoy listening to music
do you have favorite artists or bands
uh mostly classical like okay very i do
love some good
classical music i can i can agree with
that for sure um
well one of the questions that i like to
ask people is i want you to imagine for
a moment that you're in a rock and roll
band
and you guys have just released your
first album
what is the title of that album
oftentimes it's very reflective on
who you are or where you are at the time
i'm curious to know what you would name
your first album
uh i see i think it will be you know
something
abstract you know which will uh have
like uh some ambiguity
uh something like you know um uh
gear v-rack kind of thing um uh
you know ambiguity um
probably not like uh a phrase uh but
just you know one or two words
um uh maybe we can say um
uh something immemorable you know uh
people
uh will uh remember yeah um that album
name
um something like true facts
maybe
uh so something like um
uh memory rack kind of a thing um so you
know
people will implicitly think that they
need to remember that
i gotcha all right i like that that's a
tougher one for people
i know that's uh that's a tough thing to
come up with sometimes is like what are
the words that best reflect
you know what i'm thinking about or how
this stuff works
uh all right now now on to my last
question my favorite question
uh i want you to imagine for a moment
that you are trapped
in a long alley in a city
and at one end of that alley is a huge
horse-sized duck
so i want you to imagine a duck the size
of a horse and at the other end of the
alley
there are 100 small duck-sized horses
you have to get out of this alley
because otherwise you're going to get
eaten alive which one would you prefer
to
fight your way out through one giant
duck
or a bunch of tiny horses
uh so how many horses you said 100 tiny
horses
yeah about the size of a duck each not
very big
yeah uh so a couple months ago you also
interviewed my
spouse uh be like a candidate and then
after the show actually we discussed
that
and for me 100 is too much man so my
threshold is like something like 14
15. you know if there were like you know
14 ducks you know i would go
uh but then i will go with a horse-sized
dog one horse-sized duck i i think i
agree with you
i've mentioned to several of our guests
that um i think
there's something to be said for trying
to tame that horse-sized duck being able
to ride it
uh would be amazing because then you
could be on a duck and it could fly
uh there'd be a lot of opportunity there
if you just made friends with this giant
duck so
um yeah i think i agree with you i think
that would be my
that would be my perspective as well um
yeah my reasoning is the other way
around you know
uh the other side is too crowded too
crowded i mean that is
a lot and if you imagine being
surrounded by just
a hundred normal ducks that's pretty
intimidating
uh so yeah i i agree with you all right
so so you mentioned your wife delic uh
who i had a wonderful conversation with
a while ago and
um she's uh she's also a senior
principal
uh scientist right right that's that's
great
so we got to talk about her career and
her involvement in the alexa prize there
was a lot of cool things that we did
there
um and i'd like to know
well let's get a little history how how
long have you guys been married let's
start there
more than 20 years 20 years my goodness
my wife and i uh just hit 21 this year
so
congratulations yeah yeah we were in
grad school oh you met in grad school
that's great
yeah i've been married anything but oh i
see uh but you you knew each you've
known each other for quite a while
yeah yeah since uh seventh grade oh my
goodness that's excellent
that's wonderful um all right so one of
the things that i like to do
uh in your own words of course is talk
about
your history you're a senior principal
scientist you're on the alexa ai team
but one of the things that i think is
really interesting for folks um and you
and your wife are exceptions to this
rule most of the people that i talked to
didn't go to school thinking about how
am i going to apply conversation
um how am i going to build things that
really focus on conversation and voice
but it turns out that the two of you
actually have you've spent a lot of time
there so
can you give me a little background on
what your
your history is like uh i know you uh
you originally came from turkey
um but i'd love to know i'd love to know
more about where you went to school or
what you think the the meaningful
moments were in your life that kind of
the pivotal decisions you made to get to
where you are today
um i think we had the
opportunity to work with you know
pioneers in machine learning based
speech and language processing
this was you know very fortunate of us
when we
started a phd in turkey
we had a
wonderful professor who is deep into
statistical language processing and then
we had the opportunity of spending two
years during phd in the us
uh one year uh we were um an extended
intern
they called us international fellows
after a while
uh at sri international uh we worked on
uh
a daca funded program uh on um
understanding uh topics in a
conversation
uh like what are these guys talking
about and this is you know the first
time um
uh we met conversational ai and
we stayed at nine months at hopkins and
then we were
we had the opportunity of working with
gurus in speech and language processing
um and uh three months in carnegie
mellon university working on
machine translation and after uh we
graduated
uh from uh bitcoin we joined um atm t
labs you know to go
the good old uh this is you know another
thing
yeah another uh you know
thing that we were fortunate
because at that time atm key was
begin speech and language processing
they had this cool uh product uh they
were deploying on
um call centers uh because you're a t
you empower
uh most of the call centers of uh you
know fortune 500 companies
and then one bit of a thing if they were
doing this
concierge when you call
you know some company um like a you know
pharmaceutical company and you say i
want to refill my medication
or you call a i don't know a cable
provider and you say
i have a problem with my cable they were
trying to rock this call
within that company so that it is best
you know processed and uh if you think
about it you know this is one bit of
conversation layer you get input speech
you
uh try to interpret into one of the end
categories and then
um you wrote it it was called uh
how may happy and it is usually
deemed to be a pioneering conversational
ai system yeah for sure
um so yeah most people think that
conversational ai started with siri but
actually it didn't so it existed uh
before 2000.
you is it fair to say though that
something like how may i help you from
att
is it's certainly more primitive than
what we have today
but it was certainly a great example of
conversational ai i agree with you
yeah yeah of course uh but even that you
know primitive application it was super
impactful
uh because uh for the uh you know call
centers you know that business is still
uh there there are still companies you
know trying to automate call centers
um you know that's a big cost saving for
them
and then the other thing is uh it's an
opportunity because you get all these
you know millions of utterances
belonging to all these companies
and for a scientist it's like a gold
mine yeah right uh
so the the you know minimum viable thing
is you know you classify each uterus
into
one of the end classes so very quickly
we uh started expanding on that like
people say i have a problem
okay you know what is your problem it is
you know a primitive dialogue
but when you ask the follow-up question
people give specific responses
uh so um so the whole thing started to
evolve
um of course machine learning was just
starting uh speech recognition was not
as good
we were dealing with you know about 30
percent were there right
uh but you know still you know they made
uh good uh
applications no that's excellent so
uh let's well i i guess that's that's
all i
i want to talk about for now i guess on
that topic i was thinking about
well no i had one other question that i
asked at the beginning and i want to
make sure i touch on this
because i always find this really
interesting did you ever find uh that
there was a point in your career where
one option was to go the path that you
did end up taking
but do you ever look back and say wow if
i had made that decision
i would end up over here i'd be doing
this other thing
completely different instead um was
there a time where you were
torn to make a big decision in your
career and you kind of had to go one way
or the other
um topic wise no actually
so this is this is a super fruitful area
um
and this is uh one of the things where
you can have a you know food
underground head in the sky kind of
research which i
enjoy a lot um um
because you know indeed you know sky is
the limit here
um you know turing has a famous saying
like
i think 1947 by the end of the century
uh people will be able to speak to
machines without you know thinking
uh you know otherwise is not possible
you know
we sometimes joke maybe you know he's
talking about 21st century
so and i don't know whether i will see
this vision before i die
but you know this is a good actually
target uh where we
you know um uh try to you know
approximate every day and seeing uh
advances every day is super exciting i i
completely agree it's uh it's been
remarkable
just the four years that i've been on
the alexa team just the advances that
have been made
in those four years so to to understand
how we got here
i don't always have a lot of that
history and it's this is really helpful
to hear
yeah uh all right so one of the things
that you mentioned in your history was
that you
you were actually involved in some darpa
projects at sri correct
uh yeah after uh atmt we stayed at atmt
five years after that
i joined sri international uh and the
reason is
you know sra international is soft money
mainly relying on government funded
projects
and uh in 2005 they got two big uh
uh fundings uh one of them is about
um translating uh some uh spoken and
written text
and answering questions on them it is
called it was called gail
and then that was a huge boost for the
speech and language processing community
so many
uh you know academic and industrial
sites were funded by that including you
know european partners
and then the second one was uh called
calo
uh it was an ai project so it was um
trying to build an ai agent uh to
organize
your personal data like email calendar
and whatnot
so most people don't know that but kelo
is spinned off as siri
by sra international so
so this is why you know the name is so
similar um
and uh the other thing is uh when
uh you know taylor project finished you
know uh siri was actually defend me
um but then mobile phone came in 2007
and then in the spin-off they made a
brilliant choice of enabling it like a
personal uh assistant
and this k-lo project was different than
others it was not competitive it was
cooperative
so sri uh funded other uh partners
through the caleb project
and uh i was in charge of speech
understanding there
uh when kayla for example
attends uh conversations or meetings
with others okay
so so you worked on these projects what
the the time frame for that was what
uh the early 2000s
yeah no this is 2005 to 2010
um so
what were the early days like working on
stuff like that i mean we i think we all
take for granted sometimes the
the ex the access and the data and the
the reliability that we have from things
like alexa and
some of the other assistants that are
out there but what was it like then
so i would say uh
there are two big differences for both
you know
atnt and this darpa projects
uh number one is uh how we handle
data uh so privacy was uh like um
not a you know big concern uh so um
um the you know ai ethics
fairness kinds of things were not the
priority the priority is you know making
them work because they were not working
so this is pretty deep learning era
and everybody was trying to
customize the existing machine learning
algorithms or you know come up with
better features so that you know
existing machine learning algorithms
uh can actually work better and
at some point um future engineering
uh became the focus instead of um you
know data and the model
uh so this is uh one big thing um the
second
uh big thing is that um aside from the
data
so in each of these cases uh since it is
um very very you know targeted
people were building very narrow
applications
uh instead of like a generic you know
deep learning model you know which can
do you know and different tasks
uh so you have a you know um
you know some kind of uh machine
learning algorithm
you adjust that algorithm according to
your test uh
tailor it um and the field was also much
smaller
uh like at that time you know nerfs was
hundreds of people
uh we had you know speech and language
processing conferences
uh hundreds of people uh i remember
like acl conference which is like the
main nature language processing
conference
when machine learning papers were
exceptional
and nowadays it is impossible to find
any non-machine learning paper wow
so it used to be that you'd rarely see
anything and now that's all there is
yeah yeah actually the first machine
learning papers in nlp appeared like
uh late 80's um early 90's you know very
very late if you think about it for sure
um all right so one of the things that
you i mean you were very modest in your
description of your
early career but when we when we talk
about
ai and especially things related to
conversation i mean you've worked on
pretty much all of them right you talked
about the att's how may i help you
system
but you've also had a hand in siri and
cortana
and google assistant and now alexa um
what are some of the big i mean that's
amazing what are some of the big
advancements in voice ai that you've had
an opportunity to witness as part of
your career i mean it's amazing to me
uh yeah i don't think uh i know so many
people who worked on all these you know
victoria
um but you know this also gave me um
uh you know additional benefit now you
know i can't see the larger scope
because i am not limited to you know one
solution
and even though you may think
that you know all of these
conversational ai systems
approach the problem similarly they
don't so there are lots of nuances
so i had the opportunity um to get you
know better insights on
um what is possible and then what should
be next
so actually this is actually another
strength
and opportunity i had the second part of
the question
um so what is what is changed so
i talk about you know data and the
models but then on the conversational ai
set the biggest thing is
um i mentioned at atnt the focus was
core routing right and then when city
light
applications started it was more like
single shot you know set a timer for two
minutes
and then the problem is you know finding
the intent and the associated slope
and then nowadays what we are talking is
uh natural conversational dialogue
and uh i think given all the advances
saying you know speech processing
language processing
or machine learning deep learning based
algorithms
so now we are one step closer to this
vision
and so
i still uh think that you know people um
uh will not be able to
talk to machines on uh anything
they want you know it is still targeted
understanding
uh but the conversation will be much
much richer
and this is our goal in alexa ai as well
i i love it
um i mean we we as developers i a lot of
the people that are watching and
certainly myself
um i am a developer of conversations
right
i'm building an application but really
what i'm building is a way to
in infer as best i can what you said and
try to respond back with
whatever i think is the best possible
response to those things
uh but having something that's more
natural that that doesn't require a
developer to write
every single line to every single
response to every single thing i think
is
uh that's that's the future that's what
i'm really looking forward to seeing
where the the voice itself can make
decisions on its own without having to
lean heavily on a whole bunch of code
um i hope you will see those days
so everything happens you know in phases
uh first you know there are ideas and
prototypes
you will see you know early demos uh and
then product you know takes a while
yeah um all right so
let let's talk let's talk about uh the
what's coming right
there are the uh we have the annual uh
amazon devices event last week
um i don't know if you actually got a
chance to watch it but i sat there and
just
had explosion after head explosion of
cool things uh between
the echo show 10 that can rotate and
move around and
even some of the nuanced things that
they added to the fire tv i thought were
really interesting
um but
those are new devices right can you tell
me more about like the
ai driven announcements that were
announced during that event
uh yeah so uh vp of alexa ai rohit
prasad
talked about you know three big things
and actually demonstrated some of them
um
so i am currently with alexa ai a
natural understanding team
um and then this theme school is you
know building more conversational more
natural interactions so if you think
about it
this team is in charge of you know core
of the core technology for
alexa uh so whatever you say you know uh
this team is converting this into some
semantic entire accreditation
so alexa can take some action and this
can be uh you know um
uh related to uh you know the this
domain to that domain uh so this
uh team is providing the platform
technologies
uh for each of these experiences um
and this devices event was extremely
exciting and actually it was very
inspirational uh to watch
um two uh one of the big announcements
uh
in that uh event was uh
demonstrating an
interactive teaching capability
so he asked the echo device
set this light to
rohit's reading mode um and
normally you would get i am sorry i
don't understand you kind of a response
and with this you know interactive
teaching capability
alexa responded i don't know rohit's
reading mode can you teach me
and if you think about it this is
super important because now alexa is
taking action and asking for
users teaching it teaching her
to improve and this is extremely
exciting because this is another example
of a foot on the ground head in the sky
kind of an approach
um where you can demonstrate
this technology in this you know narrow
example uh but after thinking five
minutes on
where this technology can go uh it is
like the holy grail of conversational ai
there are uh you know couple papers and
maybe um
a couple phd cases on this area
uh but this is uh one of the most
uh challenging uh tasks in
conversational ai
when the agent doesn't know uh can the
agent
interact with the user to get the task
done
yeah and then there is no developer you
know there is no code you know you
directly learn from the user
um and this is you know super exciting
so this project um
was existing when i joined alexa aya
in february uh so um
the announcement was for uh smart home
for lights and thermostats so this is a
good
uh you know um uh first step uh to
showcase that actually you know uh we
can make it work
uh in a large scale production system um
and then once we work this uh the
additional features to this capability
will come
afterwards and roid also
mentioned a second one that is the
declarative concepts or
implicit intents yeah uh for example
when you say alexa it is too dark in
here
um if the action is not implicit or i
cannot see anything
right uh maybe it is daytime and you may
want to open your blinds if you have a
you know smartphone line
or maybe your mod you know turn on the
lights or maybe you have you know
multiple lights
um and in these cases instead of the
developer alexa developers you know
enumerating each of the use cases uh and
then you know writing rules for each of
the customers
um the idea is why don't we simply ask
the user right
right you know your your intent is you
know um
not explicit enough you know what do you
actually want us to do
yeah and if you know that you know there
is
there are two options you know blinds or
lights you know just ask them do you
want to turn
you know um open the blinds or turn on
the lights
um and this is another a bit of um
learning from the user uh via
interaction i
i love that um there are so many times
where
uh you know you'll talk to an assistant
uh and you
you know what you want uh but it can't
seem to figure out or understand exactly
where you're trying to route that
request
i'm sorry there there isn't a group
named living room
i called it family room of course that's
you know that kind of stuff happens all
the time so being able to infer and
interpret
um and move around i think that's uh
that's brilliant that's that's excellent
all right so um
what can what can you tell us about the
science behind these kinds of
capabilities
because it's i don't think it's very
often for our audience to get anything
more than like hey this thing works now
go ahead and try it but i'd love for you
to share with us like
what is the science behind doing
something like that look like
uh so what's happening is that
when alexa sees that you know it cannot
fulfill the request
uh it is engaging in this
sub dialogue with the user and then this
sub dialogue is the
interactive learning session with the
user
um so that means you need to have
um you know two parts in the first part
you need to understand that actually
this sub dialog will help people
so what the team has built is
something called a concept parser for
understanding the gaps
in alexa uh for example
when you say uh turn on the you know uh
set the light to steady mode
uh this parser says i know everything
except this piece
uh study mode um and then
this is uh like a flag okay uh now
uh we believe that we can actually um
imagine an interaction with the user
um and then you know um handle this
request
and uh of course
there are so many cases uh this uh model
will
uh not uh fire uh because you know we
cannot handle
all the requests um uh using this uh
technology uh so um we need to
go very carefully uh like if the user
says set
the light to oh never mind it will be
stupid to ask what do you mean by never
mind
right so after this
uh fires uh the sub dialog kicks in and
and then we ask the user uh i don't know
what you know study mode or you know
reading mode means can you teach me
um and then the
understanding the user's answer is
actually
harder than understanding the first turn
because at that point the user can't say
anything and it is uncharted territory
at this point
because it has never been done before uh
user can say you know
uh study mode means study mode or user
can say study
means you know 50 brightness uh
or user can say um study mode is the
mode
that is you know comfortable for my you
know reading
uh so you need to incorporate each one
of them or user can
be non-cooperative uh like stop cancel
uh kind of things
and then you need to uh interpret uh
the exact um meaning of this
um and uh
and then decide on the next action and
then this next section is handled by
uh our you know sub dialogue management
um
and uh for example if the user says
studymod
uh is uh the mod comfortable uh
for reading uh we can ask a second term
okay you know give me a value to ask a
more specific question
uh on top of the open handle can you
teach me
and then there's a fourth component
which we call as
a reasoning and it is important for this
implicit intent
so when the user says i cannot see
anything in here
you need to create this question to the
user you cannot simply say what can i do
for you
for example if you know that user has
you know blinds and lights you need to
ask you know
this disambiguation question if the user
has only blinds
uh you ask the confirmation question uh
so there is a bit of a logic
related to smartphone um and it is
configurable and this reasoning is also
framed as a model in the whole
architecture i i think that makes sense
right you certainly want wouldn't want
um
yeah you certainly wouldn't want to try
and just do things on a whim right you'd
want to make sure
that it's able to communicate with the
appropriate devices at the appropriate
time based on the
the types of commands users giving i
think that's that's uh that makes sense
yeah um all right so let's talk more
about this
this conversational ai that we're
describing here
uh that rohit so uh succinctly featured
during our
our launch announcements last week but
i've heard that the ability for
customers to teach alexa was actually
inspired by
how kids actually learn their first
languages so
can you can you elaborate on that what
is i mean what does that exactly mean
when we think about
how children learn versus how we want
alexa to learn from our customers
yeah if you uh look at you know the
current conversational ai systems you
know not only alexa all of them
and neither of them actually learn uh
from the interactions
like live interactions and this is
actually the norm in uh
humans uh like you know when um
you tell the kid um um oh this is a nice
bike
you know the kid you know sees the bike
run this concept
uh with you know this image and then
oh okay it is called a bike and then uh
maybe
uh next week uh you know uh she's is a
she
she's a like a you know tricycle and she
also uh look at the bike and mom
corrects
no it's a tricycle it's not a bike or uh
maybe you know reuses in some context oh
you know um
i want to you know have a bike or when
you say um
look at the red bike you know the kid
simply transforms the color red and then
says oh look at the red car
so everything is about um you know
interaction
so you you know most human kids don't
learn
the language by reading books you know
they interact you know with
uh the people around them um and this is
um this is actually very very
challenging for the conversational ai
systems
uh we try to you know build these
conversational ai systems by you know
showing them books in a way
so now this is uh probably
exciting in that respect uh like you
know
this is one case where system can learn
uh from the interaction very cool
yeah i think when you think about that
transference and how children learn i
think that's a great way to explain it
uh that thing is a red bike well that's
that's how they learn their colors and i
actually used to spend a lot of time
thinking about how awful it would be for
a parent to introduce their child to the
wrong colors
you know to call colors by the wrong
names because we as humans
i think we can agree we all see
different variations of color right
my son has some color blindness for red
and green so he doesn't really see those
colors terribly well
or he can't tell them apart um and so
we've just all kind of come up with this
common
language for what these colors are even
though they may not really be the same
colors that we're seeing
but then being able to transfer that and
apply it to oh that's a red car or this
is a red apple
um i think that that's it makes perfect
sense when we talk about humans but i
can imagine just how complicated that
must be
for a conversational ai system so uh
that's that's
yeah yeah i'm also color blind in our
case my daughter corrects me
we uh yeah this is not purple this is
buddhism my son asked for
or vice versa my son asked me for
skittles the other day and
i gave them to him but i said you can't
eat any until you sort them by color
and he had to separate all and he did a
really good job but i think he had a
couple of green ones with the red
um but otherwise he did a fantastic job
but it was uh
he was he he knew it was like come on
dad that's not fair but like
you know it was just a fun activity um
all right so you mentioned something
earlier about
uh you know when we talk about these
these learning opportunities
that it's it's wide open there's so much
there's so much possibility in what
someone could say
to alexa when when you say well what
does reading reading mode mean
um so
if a customer's response to hey can you
teach me that
isn't a valid definition what how how
does that work how does how do we handle
those kinds of situations
yeah this is uh this is why you know we
decided to go with uh
you know uh full you know dialogue in
the teaching session
uh otherwise you know you can simply
handle it with a you know single shot
uh right um but in our you know
experiments um with this
system we have realized that a good
chunk of
uh cases uh you know this is this kind
of capability is new to people they
don't even know
you know how to answer you know they
have not seen a you know conversational
ai system saying can you teach me
uh so um we have actually uh did a bunch
of
um uh variations of this prompt like
um i need a value you know can you teach
me i'm you know what is the value
or just open-ended can you teach me
uh people get you know uh most um uh
delighted when it is open-ended like can
you teach me uh but then this pushes the
burden on the ai side
because it is easier to ask you know for
brightness give me a you know percentage
between 0 and 100
um then you know it is becoming more
like directed dialogue
but when you say you know can you teach
me uh then it is a delight
and the this is why you know we have all
these you know guardrail models uh on
in the back end uh dialog manager uh
this is why we have the follow-up mode
uh sometimes people uh try um
unexpected things like uh like i cannot
see anything in here
do you want me to turn on the light uh
yes to 60 percent uh so it is uh
all of a sudden becoming you know uh
turning on the light plus
you know setting it to you know 60
brightness
or it is you know too cold in here you
know we want to turn on the thermostat
uh yes but only by one degree uh
so there are all these you know
complexities you need to take care
and you need to ask all these follow-up
questions and then
once you engage in a teaching session
with the user
uh you know you better succeed in doing
that
unless the user is you know
uncooperative so
we are trying to make sure that when we
engage into this teaching session we can
actually handle that
use case got it
uh yeah i think i think i have one
follow-up question to that
for the most part and that is every time
that we talk about this i say i'm too
cold
and the assistant comes back and says
would you like me to lower the
thermostat or
raise the thermostat for you um is there
a reason that we ask and we don't just
do
uh it is a cx problem like
conversational experience problem
um so um and there are actually
different philosophical skills if you
you know talk to these conversational
experienced people
uh some people are in the camp that you
know let's do and then you know let
people
stop us or you know negate us when we
take an action
the other school says uh you know let's
first you know get users confirmation
and even uh you can actually
uh see this you know maybe like you know
case by case
uh different approaches makes sense uh
and there are lots of cx studies
uh happening uh just on this topic very
cool
all right well that's good to know it's
just one of those things that i always
wonder as we decide to take an approach
why we decided to ask a question or why
we decided just to do the thing
um but that's uh that's that's an
excellent answer thank you
all right so you've been a part of the
conversational ai community for a while
and you've seen the evolution first hand
we've talked about all the places you've
worked and the things that you've
uh had had an impact on
what's the most notable thing about this
launch the the learning opportunities
that we have here
um besides like the obvious things where
it's like oh this will make alexa better
how does this push the industry forward
how does this change how we think about
conversation
um since you know maybe after like 2015
2016
uh you know deep learning based
approaches uh became prominent uh
in conversational ai uh and the systems
have improved a lot you know not only
a language but also you know a speech
processing site
um but if you you know look at the
experience there are still lots of cases
where
um alexa says uh i am sorry i don't know
how to do that
right and then what we are uh trying to
do is you know
can we have like a uh
you know leap uh from this uh to open a
you know orthogonal uh venue uh
to improve alexa uh because you know
every day
uh you know the models are improving
every day you know
spiritual cognition is improving
language understanding is improving
uh but then uh you need a uh
you need a you know different mechanism
and then this kind of interactive
teaching is
one way of doing that um it is not a
new idea as i mentioned before you know
you can see papers and even phd cases
uh on this area uh but
the problem is it is extremely hard
for the machine to learn the capability
uh
from the user um and people track the
narrow it in you know various ways
and um and
we believe uh now we have the sweet spot
for um enabling it um
and then this uh you know feature will
extend
we hope extend to uh more um
uh you know uh domains and um
capabilities of alexa excellent i'm
looking forward to that feature i think
that's going to be good
um okay so aside from
from that specific feature that we've
we've talked about quite a bit now and
uh certainly people got to see a slight
demonstration of that
during the device launch
what other ways are you working on
making alexa more conversational
um so the other demo um rohit
prasad vp of ai showed was um
actually very exciting uh that in that
case alexa was
following the conversation between two
humans and then one of them said alexa
joined the conversation and then it
becomes like a you know three-party
conversation
and uh alexa understands when she is
addressed
uh using uh you know speech language and
computer vision features
uh this is super cool um and uh this is
i believe um uh you know are going to
enable us
to do uh much more exciting stuff
so alexa becoming uh like a you know
member of the household
um so
at a higher level we are trying to make
alexa
more conversational more natural and
then with this interactive teaching you
know more self learning
and the the other dimension is um
enabling this kind of
rich experiences for alexa users and
developers
uh last three mars we also demonstrated
alexa conversations
uh where um developers can actually
build rich multiturn dialogue
experiences
for example the scenario there was
cleaning a night out covering
uh you know making a reservation at a
restaurant
booking an uber and then you know
checking some movies
and uh these are uh
actually all you know advancing you know
what is possible
um uh today in conversation they are
and i am actually very uh glad seeing
all these
uh science efforts uh leading alexa very
cool
um all right so i i think that i think
the idea of joining the conversation is
actually
really pretty cool there's a number of
times where
you want that to start and then you you
want alexa to kind of back
back out of the conversation i just
needed you for a moment um
i i think that's that's actually
absolutely going to change the way that
people think about using
their assistance in their homes because
right now it's a very one-off right you
you turn you look at everybody in the
room and you're like all right hold on a
second i have to talk to alexa and like
it's a
it's a very meaningful um almost i need
some silence process to be able to make
this thing happen
and then once you get your answer then
everybody can go back to doing what
they're doing
but the way it was illustrated at least
in the video that i saw
when they were talking with the echo
show 10 they were just
talk they would turn and talk to the
device when they wanted an answer there
otherwise they would
talk amongst themselves and i just think
that that's a game changer for a number
of
uh applications of voice yeah
so are there any other customer facing
maybe things that people are watching
that they've seen
are there any launches or improvements
that you personally are most proud of
things that you've
uh invested your time and energy into
uh you mentioned echo show 10. uh i
think this was
very inspirational uh because echo show
10 you know following
you know the person uh in the room uh
this is
um
this is so exciting um i believe the
future of conversational layer is you
know multi-modal conversational ai
and then with this kind of uh devices
um uh
there are so many you know exciting new
capabilities
alexa can offer to customers um
and um this is also related to the you
know grounding i mentioned you know
kids uh uh learning you know this is a
bike you know this is a red bike
now you know uh alexa will have the ice
you know
um uh in this demo alexis eyes you know
we're following you
uh this is a very nice demonstration of
computer vision
and when we you know mix these kinds of
technologies with
uh speech and language processing uh
there are so many other cool things we
can do yeah
uh well i will tell you i've i've
already uh checked the box on the
amazon.com website
to get echo show 10 inside my house as
soon as i possibly can so i'm really
looking forward to that being able to
have it pivot and rotate as i
move around and um see see what's
possible
uh from from some of this yeah so i i
know that there's
there's a number of interesting blogs
that cover a lot of the topics that we
covered today
um like teachable moments and uh
you know as the science advances um i
think that
the best place to find a lot of this
information is on amazon.science
which if you guys haven't had an
opportunity to go there uh it's a
fantastic website that includes videos
like this
but also lots and lots of information
about the kinds of research and outcomes
that our amazon science organization is
working on
so if you'd like to know more about
those things you can jump on there
i think you can even subscribe to their
blog so there's lots of
other great information that you can
find but amazon.science that's the place
that you
you'd want to go so goku i i can't thank
you enough for joining me today this has
been
uh eye opening for me for sure uh
the fact that there is a person that has
been working on
all of these different conversational
agents for so long
uh and that i got to spend an hour
talking to him is just it's fantastic
and i
i really appreciate you taking the time
so are there any other closing thoughts
or anything you want to share with the
audience before we wrap things up here
uh no no thanks jeff thanks for you know
inviting me
it was pleasure for me certainly well i
want to thank everybody for tuning in
uh thank you all for your participation
and attention
and this video will be posted up on the
amazon.science website very soon
so keep an eye out for that if you want
to refer people to it or whatever
but thank you again gokan thank you to
the audience for being here
uh and thank you to everyone we will uh
we'll be back here again very very soon
bye